I often get questions and accusations
thrown at me regarding my stance or my
look on poverty or being poor or being
broke there's a difference between being
poor and being broke poor as a state of
mind broke as I'm passing through I've
been broke but I've never been poor I've
been so broke I couldn't pay attention
but I've never been poor so poverty or
to be poor is caused by three possible
things and really only three possible
things one is you have the unfortunate
situation to be born in an area of the
world where the political climate is
corrupt unstable and economic activity
is almost zilch
there is no economy for you to
participate in because your government
is so horrible and oh are other reasons
we call these third-world countries
that's a valid reason for poverty and
obviously it's no fault of the person
that's living in that situation that's
in poverty
the second reason it's no fault of the
person that has is poor or in poverty is
when other people oppress of the poor
that's a biblical term you don't hear
that much anymore to be oppressed to be
put down to be taken advantage of
and you see that in developing countries
as well as you know as well as you know
a thriving economy like the United
States there's plenty of you on the poor
area of town you will see the businesses
that feed on the poor check cashing
title pawn rent-to-own
payday lenders you don't see these in
the rich end of town because rich people
eat dirt before they do that stuff
they're not going to do that because
they know how detrimental it is and now
short-term thinking it is but they these
businesses are parasites that take
advantage of the poor and cry and
further poverty along the third reason
people are poor is stupid decisions when
I went broke it wasn't because anybody
oppressed me
because I'm stupid the stupid decision
said I continue to make those stupid
decisions I would continue to be broke
there's a cause and effect of sowing and
reaping in our lives if you live in
North America you are not in an economic
climate that holds you down
listen snowflake you visit some places
where they really hold you down okay
you're not held back you're a whiner
okay
stupid all right now are there things in
America that will oppress the poor yes
are their mindsets that that keep you in
the gutter
yes but actual economic activity is
around here for you to participate in
and has cause and effect and get out of
there what's your plant is what grows if
you plant nothing the government's not
going to come along and plant something
when it rains you're gonna have mud and
you can eat mud pies and make a mud hut
but if you plant corn you'll have corn
voila
when it rains and don't be shocked that
corn grows if you plant corn if you do
rich people habits with money and have
rich people mindsets with money
eventually you will be rich people if
you do poor people stuff with money and
you're rich eventually you will be poor
people have you ever seen a trust-fund
baby do stupid stuff if you're seeing
somebody win the lottery and lose
everything they do poor people's stuff
with their money short-term thinking and
they get stupid and they lose their
money I've done both I know how it feels
article in Bloomberg today Americans
spend tens of billions of dollars on
government-run lotteries each year but
as income inequality widens low earning
households spend a disproportionate
amount of money on lottery tickets
according to a new study honey anything
they do they income inequality it's
always been that low-income households
are supporting the lottery the lowest
income households in the US on average
spend four hundred twelve dollars
annually on lotto tickets which is
nearly four times the hundred and five
dollars spent by the highest earning
households on
average according to a study released on
Wednesday almost three and ten Americans
in the lowest income bracket play the
lottery once a week compared to two in
ten who earned more than that lotteries
have become an alternative mechanism of
social mobility a way of achieving
financial success in an economy that's
increasingly burette of those
opportunities said Jonathan Cohen a PhD
candidate at the University of Virginia
I don't even wanna know how much debt
Jonathan has um there's an
understandable belief that the economy
is rigged and your best chance of making
it out is getting rich through the
lottery no Jonathan they're not trapped
and the economy's not rigged you're a
PhD student honey you haven't lived in
the real world long we'll get you out
here and show you how this stuff really
works the way it really works is this
four hundred and twelve dollars annually
is just under $35 a month $35 a month
invested in the growth stock mutual fund
a good one with a long track record 99
times out of 100 if you do that from age
25 to age 65 you would have about four
hundred and eleven thousand dollars in
your nest egg $35 a month instead of
spending it on a lottery if you put it
in the lottery you know what you will
have at retirement nothing it does not
cause upward mobility fool it causes the
theft of money from poor people in the
name of the government fool has nothing
to do with wealth innate wealth
inequality it has to do with stupid
decisions and a government preying on
the poor and using the lottery to do it
knowing that the high percentage of the
lottery tickets are sold in lower-income
households this crap continues oh but we
use it to fund education tuition oh
here's a great idea let's have a whole
bunch of poor people send middle income
people and rich people's kids to school
for free I think that increases wealth
inequality
this is stupid it's oppressing the poor
and for people that are playing the
lottery or stupid you're stupid well
it's the only way I'm getting out listen
if you walk from your house one mile to
the market to buy a lottery ticket you
are 12 times more likely to be struck by
lightning twice the
to buy the ticket that's the probability
of you winning that's a statistical fact
that is not going to occur in your life
but if you invest thirty five dollars
instead of wasting it in a decent growth
stock mutual fund over at your work they
got a thing called a 401k plan you'll
have four hundred eleven thousand
dollars when you turn 65 oh let me help
you with that at eight percent that's
thirty three thousand dollars a year
with never touching the nest egg that's
$2,500 $2,700 a month 435 buckaroo turn
and it happens every time you do this if
you plant corn you grow corn if you
plant nothing you will have nothing and
this this foolish idea that the way the
poor are not going to be poor anymore is
to be taken advantage of by the lottery
is absolutely asinine folks this is
causing a fact this is your government
preying on the poor and if you're poor
or if you're not and you're playing the
lottery let me tell you what the lottery
is it's a tax on stupid people that
can't do math that's what the lottery is
this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]